♪ ♪
>> Jeanine: MORE BRUTAL RUSSIA
SHELLING IN UKRAINE HAS BOTH
SIDES TRIED TO REACH THE
CEASE-FIRE DURING A NEW ROUND OF
TALKS.
UKRAINE SAID THERE IS POSSIBLE
ROOM FOR COMPROMISE DESPITE
LVIV.
THE SHOCKING REPORTS FROM
MARIUPOL FORCING BOMBING OF A
THEATER WHERE CIVILIANS WERE
SHELTERING.
IN KYIV WITH THE LATEST,
TREY YINGST.
>> JUDGE GOOD AFTERNOON AN
EXTREMELY DISTURBING REPORT OUT
OF SOUTHERN UKRAINIAN CITY OF
MARIUPOL WHERE RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
BOMBED A THEATER THAT THIS WEEK
HAD HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE HIDING IN
FROM RUSSIA STRIKES.
YOU CAN SEE IN THE SATELLITE
IMAGES BEFORE THE BOMBING IN THE
FRONT AND BACK OF THIS THE ATER,
PEOPLE HAD WRITTEN THE WORD
"CHILDREN" AND RUSSIA TO LET THE
FORCES KNOW THIS IS A PLACE FOR
CIVILIANS, NOT A PLACE FOR
MILITARY.
THE DESTRUCTION AND AFTERMATH OF
THE STRIKE TODAY.
THE RESCUE WORKERS ARE STILL
LOOKING FOR ANYONE WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN IN SIGHT AT THE TIME
OF THE STRIKE.
BUT JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
RUSSIAN FORCES TARGETING
CIVILIAN AREAS.
HERE IN THE CAPITAL OF KYIV.
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO ADVANCE.
THEY ARE TARGETING BUILDINGS
INSIDE THE CITY APPEAR THIS
MORNING TWO PEOPLE INJURED AFTER
12 STORY RESIDENTIAL BUILDING
HIT WITH A RUSSIAN SHELL.
RESCUE WORKERS EVACUATED OTHERS
AND POLICE AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
THE UKRAINIAN ERA FENCE REMAINS
ACTIVE OVER THE CITY AS RUSSIA
TRIES TO ATTACK FROM THE AIR.
THEY HAVE LAUNCHED COUNTER
OFFENSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS VIDEO CAPTURES UKRAINIAN
STRIKE AGAINST THE RUSSIAN TANK
IN THE EASTERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE SOUTHERN CITY OF
MARIUPOL, THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ABLE TO ESCAPE THE CAR THROUGH
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS THOUGH
THE DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER OF
UKRAINE SAID THE VIOLATION OF
THE RUSSIAN AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
EVEN BEING HELD HOSTAGE.
SHE HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
>> OCCUPANTS WERE SHOOTING AT
HUMANITY, CONVOYS, BUSES,
RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND POINTS OF
GATHERING OF PEOPLE AS WELL AS
TAKING HOSTAGES AND ACCOMPANYING
PEOPLE.
SO, HE HAS STILL KEPT HOSTAGE.
>> A SHORT WHILE AGO AIR RAID
AND THE CAPITAL CITY AND SMALL
ARMS FIRE IN THE DISTANCE AFTER
KYIV HAS A 24-HOUR CURFEW.
>> Jeanine: THANKS,
TREY YINGST.
YOU KNOW, SANDRA, YOU KNOW WE
WATCH THE BUILD UP.
WE WATCH THE 40-MILE CONVOY DO
VERY LITTLE.
BUT NOW IT SEEMS THAT THEY HAVE
GOTTEN WORD HE HAS BRUTAL AS
POSSIBLE.
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS, IT IS
ALMOST LIKE, YOU KNOW, HIT THE
CIVILIANS, HIT THE CHILDREN
COMMIT THE REFUGEE CORRIDORS,
THE HOSPITALS.
I MEAN, IT HAS BECOME MORE MORE
BRUTAL.
IS HE DESPERATE, PUTIN?
>> Sandra: ABSOLUTELY.
YOU WATCH THAT AND YOU WATCH THE
ATTACK ON CIVILIANS WE HAD
TODAY.
YOU GO BACK TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT AIRPOWER.
WE HAD A TWEET DURING COMMERCIAL
BREAK FROM NIKKI HALEY, WE NEED
TO LET THE CATASTROPHIC
SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA'S ENERGY
SECTOR.
TO GREG'S POINT, THE CONSULATE
HAS BEEN DECIMATED BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT A TEXT
LIKE THAT, THERE IS MILITARY
MIGHT AND MONEY BEHIND THAT
BY THE MIC FIGHT.
IT IS INTERESTING THING TO BRING
UP GOING BACK TO ZIELINSKI'S
POINT THIS MORNING IN ADDITION
TO EVERYTHING HE'S ASKING FOR,
HE IS ASKING US TO CUT OFF ALL
AMERICAN COMPANIES FROM DOING
BUSINESS IN RUSSIA.
NO RUSSIAN GOODS AT AMERICAN
PORTS.
THERE ARE WAYS WE COULD BE
CUTTING OFF VLADIMIR PUTIN IN
THIS MOMENT.
THERE ARE SOME CRAZY STORIES
ABOUT CHINA, OBVIOUSLY CHINA,
THEIR OIL IS ON SALE RIGHT NOW.
YOU TALK ABOUT SAUDI ARABIA
WILLING TO CUT OFF THE U.S.
DOLLAR FOR TRANSFERRING OIL
SALES TO CHINA AND USING TAIWAN
FOR THAT.
AND DEVALUING THE U.S. DOLLAR.
SO THIS COULD BE CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND IT COMES TO THE ECONOMY.
AND DECIMATING HIM FROM THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO RAMP UP
THE FIGHT THE LEVEL YOU JUST
ADJUSTED.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, JUST E,
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING, SO MANY
COMPANIES DECIDED ON THEIR OWN D
PEER THEY SAID WE WOULD NOT DO
THIS TO RUSSIA.
THEN WE NEED ZELENSKYY WHO IS IN
THE MIDDLE OF A WAR, PROBABLY
THE MOST STRESSED GUY ON THE
WORLD, ONE OF THEM AND HE HAS TO
REMIND BIDEN, MAYBE YOU WANT TO
DO WHAT SANDRA IS TALKING ABOUT
DOING.
IT IS REALLY PATHETIC HOW WE ARE
NOT DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
STOP PUTIN.
>> Jesse: THERE IS MORE WE ARE
DUMB I CAN DO WHEN WE ARE
KEEPING THAT IN OUR BACK POCKET.
>> Jeanine: WHY?
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO WRAP
RAMP IT UP IF HE GOES AND KILL
ZELENSKYY OR SOMETHING WORSE.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP A FEW BULLETS
IN THE CHAMBER.
I DON'T THINK GERMANY IS READY
TO GO IN YET.
THEY MIGHT EVENTUALLY GET THERE.
HERE IS HOW PUTIN SURVIVES THIS,
HERE IS HOW RUSSIA SURVIVES THIS
PURITY HAS TO CUT A DEAL WITH
ZELENSKYY.
IF HE KILLS ZELENSKYY, HE IS
WORSE, THE RUSSIAN BIN LADEN AT
THAT POINT.
SANCTIONS GO FROM SIX DOWN TO A
TEN AND YOU LOADED UP.
YOU HAVE TO ECONOMY OF MONGOLIA
YOU ARE LOOKING AT.
WHAT HE WILL DO IS ENCIRCLE THE
CAPITAL AS FAST AS POSSIBLE.
THAT CHANGES THE DYNAMIC PEER
THAT IS WHEN THE REAL
NEGOTIATION STARTS.
ZELENSKYY HAS TO DECIDE, AM I
GOING TO NEGOTIATE OR DIE?
IF HE DIES, THAT IS ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IF YOU NEGOTIATES, PUTIN WILL
SAY I TAKE THIS IN THE SOUTH,
EAST AND WILL NEGOTIATE
NEUTRALITY.
THEN I WILL BACK UP AND TRY TO
TAKE THE SANCTIONS AWAY.
THAT IS HIS ONLY GAME HERE THAT
IS HIS ONLY ENDING AT THIS
POINT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS IS NOW
THE BEST ARMED INSURGENCY IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND.
THESE GUYS ARE ARMED TO THE
TEETH.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE AMERICAN
REVOLUTIONARY WAR, THE
VIETNAM WAR, YOU KNOW HOW LONG
INSURGENCIES CAN LAST HERE AT
ALMOST 20 YEARS WAS THE LAST
ONE.
SO, WE DIDN'T HAVE SANCTIONS
HITTING US EVERYDAY.
SO THEY ARE UP AGAINST THE CLOCK
AND THAT IS WHY THEY HAVE TO
MOVE SO FAST TO CIRCLE THE
CAPITAL.
>> Jeanine: YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE THINGS ZELENSKYY SAYS THAT
RUSSIA NOW IN THE APPARENT
NEGOTIATIONS, THE BACKGROUND,
TALKING MORE REALISTICALLY AND
SAVING THERE IS CAUTIOUS
OPTIMISM THAT KYIV SHOULD
RENOUNCE AMBITIOUS AND JOIN NATO
WHICH ZELENSKYY SAID HE WOULD
ALREADY DO.
AND PROMISED NOT TO HOST
MILITARY BASES IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROTECTION FROM ALLIES.
>> Geraldo: HERE IS MY PROBLEM
WITH NEGOTIATIONS AND THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.
I'M ALL FOR NEGOTIATIONS BUT
HERE HOWEVER, YOU HAVE A BABY
KILLER.
I HATE TO USE AND I MEAN
SOMETIMES I CHOOSE TO BE
HYPERBOLIC.
>> Greg: NOT YOU, GERALDO.
>> Geraldo: BUT THIS IS TRUE.
THIS MAN HAS TARGETED WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
>> Jeanine: BUT HOW DOES IT
AND MATT, GERALDO?
>> Geraldo: MY POINT IS GOING
BACK TO WHAT JESSE AND GREG HAVE
SAID, THIS IS MOTHER RUSSIA IS
NOW HAS CANCER.
AND THE CANCER IS GOING TO KILL
MOTHER RUSSIA UNLESS MOTHER
RUSSIA EXERCISES THIS DEAL.
THERE IS NO WAY, I BELIEVE, THAT
THIS MAN CAN NEGOTIATE ANYTHING.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT RUSSIA CAN
HAVE HIM AS THE FACE GOING
FORWARD AND TRY TO INTEGRATE
HIMSELF BACK IN THE WORLD
ECONOMY.
HOW DO YOU FLY BACK TO MOSCOW
NOW?
KNOWING THEY UNLEASHED HELL ON
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
ON EARTH?
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE DOING HERE
THEY ARE IN THE BUSINESS OF
DESTROYING, UTTERLY, A CIVILIZED
INDUSTRIALIZED NATION.
THEY HAVE TAKEN THE 21ST CENTURY
COUNTRY THERE AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO SEND IT BACK TO THE
STONE AGE.
HOW DO YOU NEGOTIATE WITH THIS
PERSONAL?
>> Jeanine: HOW DOES IT END IS
THE BETTER QUESTION?
>> Geraldo: IT ENDS RIGHT
HERE.
VERY BRIEF, VERY BRIEF, VERY,
VERY BRIEF.
RUSSIA GETS EXHAUSTED BECAUSE OF
THE HERO WITH SOME OF THE
UKRAINIANS HERE ARE THOSE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS START GOING
HOME.
THE SAME WAY THEY DID IN 1917
WHEN THEY SAID "SCREW YOU, WE
ARE GOING HOME."
>> Jeanine: ALL RIGHT.
>> Greg: I HATE TO SAY GERALDO
HAD A GOOD POINT, BUT THE FACT
IS, ZELENSKYY DID SOMETHING VERY
SMART IN WHICH HE ACTUALLY
TALKED TO THE RUSSIANS SOLDIERS.
HE TALKED TO THE RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS ABOUT THE FUTURE,
ASSUMING YOU WILL BE ALIVE THEN.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE AFTER
THIS.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GO HOME?
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO FACE YOUR
FAMILY?
THAT WAS PRETTY IMPORTANT -- IT
WASN'T TODAY BUT SOME OTHER
TIME.
BUT I DO THINK YOU KNOW, PUTIN
COULD BE THE FACE OF RUSSIA IF
RUSSIA DECIDES TO BECOME
NORTH KOREA.
APPEAR THAT HIS ONLY
WAY HE CAN SURVIVE.
WHAT DID THEY USED TO CALL IT A
HAMLET IN THE COUNTRY?
RUSSIA IS GOING TO BE SO CUT
OFF -- I WAS TALKING TO MY WIFE
TODAY BECAUSE I HAVE RELATIVES
IN UKRAINE AND MOSCOW.
AND IT'S LIKE, THEY ARE
DISGUSTED AND REPULSED.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE TERRIFIED IF THE COPS
TAKE THEIR PHONES AND LOOK AT
THEIR PHONES.
IT IS LIKE PRETTY MUCH OVER FOR
PUTIN AS A WORLD LEADER.
HE MAY LAUGH AND HE COULD TAKE
AN OFFERING, AS THEY CALL IT,
BUT AFTER THAT WHEN HE GOES
BACK, SOMEONE WILL TAKE CARE OF
HIM.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T -- TO YOUR
POINT, THEY CAN'T GO FORWARD
WITH HIM AS THEIR FACE.
IT IS LIKE, HE HAS THE BED.
THERE IS NO USE TO HAVE HIM
AROUND ANYMORE.
I THINK RUSSIA WILL TAKE CARE OF
HIM.
>> Jeanine: I THINK IT DEPENDS